at CBS News poll out this morning finds
many Americans disagree with the
president when he says the Trump Russia
story is a hoax 59% say it is very
likely or somewhat likely that Trump
associates had improper communications
with Russia's government 40 percent of
people in our poll approve of president
Trump's job performance and that is
nearly unchanged from last month now the
White House denies trying to block
former acting Attorney General Sally
Yates from testifying to Congress about
Russia the president fired gates in
January after she told Justice
Department lawyers not to defend the
first version of his refugee and travel
ban Jeffrey gazes on Capitol Hill with
the new controversy over Sally Yates
Jeff good morning good morning the house
investigation has officially stalled
bogged down by finger-pointing and
accusations the latest flashpoint is the
testimony of Sally Yates who was also
the official to inform the White House
that former national security adviser
Michael Flynn had misled the vice
president about his contacts with the
Russian ambassador the White House did
not respond and took no action that
prevented miss Yates from testifying an
exasperated Sean Spicer dismissed
accusations that the White House sought
to delay former acting Attorney General
Sally Yates from testifying we encourage
them to go ahead but to suggest in any
way shape or form that we stood in the
way that is 100% false CBS News has
obtained this letter from the Trump
Justice Department to the attorney
representing Yates it warns that there
is a limit to what she could reveal in
her testimony and that she needs to
consult with the White House on the same
day she received this letter the
chairman of House Intelligence Committee
congressman Devin Nunez canceled Yates's
scheduled testimony it gets stranger and
stranger frankly more bizarre every day
since noon as announced late last week
that he had been shown intercepted
communications involving members of the
Trump transition team the House
Intelligence Committee investigation
into Russian meddling in the election
has been in disarray
on Tuesday Nunez was facing more
questions about whether he was working
with the White House to delay his
committees investigation while also
dismissing calls for him to step aside
are you gonna stay as chairman and run
this investigation oh why would I not
this is what cover-up behavior looks
like Democrat Eric Shaw well who sits on
the Intelligence Committee says Nunez
his actions leave doubts about whether
he can lead the investigation right now
the American people want transparency
and what they are getting are more and
more smoke bombs the House Intelligence
Committee has had just one hearing on
Russia no others currently scheduled the
Senate Intelligence Committee is
expected to hold its first hearing
tomorrow and a press conference later on
today Charlie Jeff thanks